[Music]
sex don't avoid that it's like one of
the best parts you're willing to have a
sexless marriage you're willing to have
a marriage where you don't have
conversations with your best friend in
the world you're about to lose
everything you brother have to stop
wearing anxiety as an identity
[Music]
badge what is going on this is John
brother the Dr John Boney show so glad
that you're with
us wow we're talking parenting mental
health marriage whatever you got going
on in your life your emotional health
those kids their schools your work uh
whatever you got going on we're here for
you we'll sit with you when things get
sideways and my promise is you're not
going to do this alone and we'll walk
with you whatever you're going through
if you want to be on this show give me a
buzz 1844 4693 3291 leave a message and
we'll holl back girl at you I Ain a holl
back girl and you can go to John
dooney.com
askas and fill out the form and we'll
get in touch with you by the way I just
got to say two important things
important thing number one last night
was the big book launch party out here
and it was a book launch that turned
into a punk rock show and it was off the
it was just incredible all y'all were
there it was so fun dude y'all are the
best so the best everybody man it was
amazing super fun it was so much fun
super fun and we're all so tired today I
know but that's okay I can hardly see
straight yes yeah yeah um and my weekly
low returns and it was awesome Ben
brought the Thunder like always seeing
my little daughter out there in the
audience singing Taylor Swift with all
of her Gusto and waving that little
phone it was that's a highlight of my
life all right I'm going to say
something that um shows feelings for me
and it's going to make you take a
compliment so here we go I'll just take
it like a champ yeah I am so proud of
you I think we all are thank you I think
I'm assuming we all are thank you yeah
because not because I mean last night
yes it was great it was fun we had a
great time your talk was awesome
but I we had some stories last night
from
fans literally I was about to kill
myself and this thing popped up yeah
literally life-saving stories because of
the work you've done and I know we're so
so proud to be a part of this gang all
of us but the work that you put into the
book into every talk into this show just
we're all very very proud of you and we
hope you know that well I appreciate
that I accept that and thank you you
accepted that nicely untable my feet are
like uh I'm like running in place
underneath the desk but it's good no
thank you for that that was awesome and
it was cool man hearing all those
stories was wild um people it was in
that VIP room number one like that
people paid all that extra money just to
come hang out and we did like a kind of
a private version of the show but more
than that there was like four people
from Nashville everyone was from
everywhere from New Hampshire and
Florida and New Mexico and British
Columbia col I have her letter right
here and it's amazing yeah it was just I
mean people came in from all over so
yeah dude we're starting to movement
it's pretty rad if people just like this
way kind of sucks let's do it
differently like I don't even know what
that means but let's go um sing Taylor
Swift at the top of our lungs with a
podcaster and we'll start there or we'll
sing some old poison songs and then
there's a second thing we have to talk
about I don't remember when this show
came out but 2020 I no it was before
that it was it was this this particular
episode I'm GNA talk
about you said something about um
DayQuil oh yeah that was just a couple
weeks ago and I made a reference to It's
Always Sunny because it's when I'd come
back from being sick and I was pretty
much high as a kite to you're pretty
much high as a kite always I wish to
tell you how many direct messages I've
received about it's always sunny yeah
we've gotten so many
emails this show is basically just a
It's Always Sunny fan show I think is
what we're running here it's
unbelievable I've never no call no like
man John your advice is so good on this
thing you quote it's always sunny one
time cuz you said something about it a
couple of days ago and I was like okay
whatever I hadn't heard anything and I
kid you not that afternoon I've probably
had 15 to 20 emails that day of about
that I'm talking hundreds of direct best
it's amazing day man that's what hits
out of all the work that's what hits
fighter of the night man whoa all right
let's go out to Harrisburg and talk to
relle what up
relle what is up Dr John what's up up
how we
doing I'm doing well how are you just I
mean if I had more fun I'd probably
asleep I I don't know what that means
but hey so what's what's going on how
can I help yeah so thanks so much for
taking my call uh my question for you is
how can I stop obsessing over my weight
loss journey and learn to love the body
that I'm in oh man tell me about
it yeah so I'm 33 I'm a stay home to two
little boys who are both allergic to
sleep
so I don't have a lot of time and when I
do have time I'm usually pretty tired um
but kind of my history like I've always
been a big girl um not always like I
mean always chubby but I'm tall just
never been one of those cute petite
little things um always struggled with
body dysmorphia and still do um did all
the things in adoles and even in early
adulthood as far as diets you know the
Weight Watchers The Slim Fast all the
things it wasn't really until the last
five to seven years that I really got on
track and started looking at my health
and what I would consider a healthy way
it's really I love mine pump the Mind
pump guys and Dr Lane Norton it's you
and those two podcasts on constant
repeat over here great guys yeah yeah so
um like I said I have two little boys
worked really really hard to have
healthy pregnancies with them um just
kept walking kept strength training the
first one I lost all the M weight
immediately I was really blessed with
the healthy pregnancy that I was able to
keep up with that I know not that's not
the situation for all women but luckily
it was for me that time um and also at
the second one again really tried to to
not gain a a ton of weight tried to get
a healthy amount of weight working with
my doctors to keep that a healthy
pregnancy as well um but after my second
baby as I continued to breastfeed every
single pound that I had lost came back
so uh that little boy just turned two
and I'm currently sitting at right now
the same weight that I did when I walked
in with an almost 8 pound baby in my
belly okay um I just found myself when I
have to go places with my family and you
know we have to get dressed up uh which
for me is anything but leggings I find
myself cranky because I'm wearing
clothes and sizes I've never worn before
um and it's just it's really affecting
all facets of my life because I am so
discontent with my current body
yeah dude thanks for saying that out
loud I know that's not fun to say out
loud huh yeah it's
embarrassing I have this like beautiful
specimen of a husband who can like eat
an entire sleeve of Oreos and maintain a
sixpack which is super annoying it'll
get him it'll catch him it will catch
him just wait it'll just one day he'll
it'll it'll get him
um did you grow up in a house where
um people watch what you
ate uh yeah yeah so that's wired into to
you the um oh honey that shirt makes you
look pudgy let's wear the other
shirt yeah yeah it wasn't necessarily
even comments towards me but very much
comments about themselves there you go
and um yeah never yeah luckily nothing
ever pointed towards me but just hearing
this the negative self talk yeah yeah
and their negative selft talk became
what you saw in the world and then what
you saw in the world became your
negative selft talk about other people
and then that became the story you tell
about
yourself um yeah what' your husband say
about all
this um he is incredibly encouraging um
he OB you know he he acknowledges uh you
know that obviously I have gained weight
CU you know it's a lot of times all I
can talk about um he still makes me feel
loved and attractive to the best of his
ability but obviously if it's not
something like he can only do so much
with his words and his actions and I
think and he kind of gets frustrated
sometimes um as I as I think anyone
would to I mean it's this Obsession for
me that I'm just I it's always this well
I'll be happier when I've lost the
weight when I can fit into the old jeans
when I can walk next to you and feel
like proud to you know be your
wife how have you equated
that how you've
equated a number on a scale and with the
size of your pants
with then he'll love
me and you're describing ways when he's
like getting frustrated because he's is
watching the woman that he loves and
that he's sexually attracted to and that
he is like seeing being an amazing mom
of his two
kids
um his frustration is that she can't see
how
much he loves
her
yeah where's that story come
from because it's not true I yeah I
don't um but you you've equate you've
equated like weight loss with
value yeah um I think what's just so
frustrating for me is I feel like I'm
putting in the
work you know I'm watching what I eat
and I'm working
out and I it's not
working and hold on I you how old are
your
kids uh just turn two and just turn four
okay so you're living inside of a
blender without a top on
it and you're
exhausted and did you have a picture of
what let's put weight aside because I
think that's
symptomatic did you think being a mom
was going to feel different than
this yeah I I really struggled um with
postpartum depression yeah with both of
them and I also struggled with a lot of
infertility before them and it's real
easy when you struggle with infertility
you struggle with
postpartum that these kids this family
is going to rescue me it's going to feel
like I'm finally
here very similar to the way sometimes
and again I'm over genderize this but
the way a man says man when I finally
make six figures when I finally get a
$100,000 a year then I'll fill in the
blank and part of that compounding
challenge is you're holding your baby
and you and your hormones are all over
the place and you're sitting there in
this postpartum Funk and you start to
think a good mom wouldn't feel like this
a good mom who'd struggle with
infertility and holding her baby would
should be grateful and should be feeling
like this and I
don't so yet again there's another notch
in the there's something not right about
me I've never been cute and petite I
married a smoke show I've never been
this my parents weren't enough I'm not
this and it should be feeling like this
so let's have another kid we just need
to have a
family and all of a sudden you're
sitting in the reality four-year-olds
are insane they're literally insane they
are weed eaters with ears and eyes and
then you have a two-year-old that's in
that Gap I call it like the fourth the
fourth dimension of hell where they're
kind of human but also kind of not right
they're like humans but you kind of
still change diapers are kind of like
Mom I pooped ah and then can I have a
snack can I have a snack can I have a
snack can I have a
snack and it was all supposed to feel
different yeah yeah I had this picture
in my mind that I would you know be
taking my babies on walks and and I
think because I thought I struggled so
much to get pregnant with
them that I would be exempt from all of
the postpartum stuff yeah because I I
struggled so
much and I think you don't and that
shouldn't happen yeah yeah and so
I I I say something weird Okay do you
probably have weight to lose yeah I I
believe you yeah I believe you no
question
um does your husband love you yeah I
believe you on that
too did your those crazy little boys win
the lottery getting you as their mama
yeah I believe
that I also am going to challenge
you this story has to stop with
you the story that you picked up from
your parents and the story that they
picked up from their
parents that I'll be worth loving I'll
be worth being proud of when fill in the
blank that has to stop with you because
those little boys will pick that up too
is that fair I feel like I'm I feel like
I'm already noticing it where I notice
my four-year-old coming up and saying
mommy I did this are you proud of me
yeah and i' tell him I'm proud of you no
matter what you know even if you didn't
do that I'm proud of you but I notice
okay I'm G to tell I'm going to tell you
something hard and I I hesitate to tell
moms this because I don't want you to
internalize this and make this about
fault I want you to make this about
opportunity do you promise you can do
that if I tell you this I I can yeah
you're a littley
boy has a radar that he's scanning the
environment all the time to make sure
he's
safe and he feels mom's not
okay and when he asks you are you proud
of me do you see me what he's asking is
am I helping you feel
okay yeah he's trying to heal the
tension in his
environment and I say this with all love
in my heart for you my friend that's not
his job that's your job absolutely
and so I want you to not look at this as
a weight loss win or loss or a weight
loss failure or a I've always been a big
girl now I'm just the thing is happening
to me that I swore wouldn't happen which
is I'm going to become one of those
ladies that just lets himself go that's
not the
conversation we'll get
there the conversation is I thought my
life was going to feel different than it
does right now and I thought it was
going to look different I thought my
experience of two healthy beautiful
little baby boys in a smoke show husband
was going to heal this inner child this
kid that I've never really liked she's
never been pretty enough she's never
been cute she's never been petite she's
never been those
girls and I thought these external
things would do it and it's
not that's the place you have to go
to and as a guy who struggled with body
dysmorphia I am telling you it wasn't
until and you've heard me do it on the
show I I wasn't until my counselor
caught
me she was like uh she golf clapped me
and she was like oh you're real smart
and you have lots of words
congratulations you're smart and then
that's when she made me make a fist and
put it in my chest and say the words I
love this guy and I couldn't make those
words come out of my
mouth and she smiled and she goes there
it
is you can have the perfect workout
program the perfect exercise program the
perfect ACT or DBT or rebt the perfect
therapeutic
modality but if at the end of the day
you don't look in the mirror and like
who you
see all of it is going to be a roller
coaster ping pong match for the rest of
your
life and so I think the work here is
we'll get to the I I trust that you're
disciplined my gosh and I trust you can
quote unquote lose you know the calories
and I trust that you can EX exercise I
don't think that's your challenge right
now I think your body is still rattling
like a snow globe because you don't like
you tell me if I'm
wrong no I I don't think I could do that
I don't you know when I'm even like
getting you know dressed for the day and
I look in the mirror I'm like I can't
think this body that I prayed for so
long would give me these children that
are just such blessings I even can't
find myself to like thank God and thank
my body for doing that because there's
just nothing I look in the mirror that I
like there you
go will you make me a promise that
you'll call somebody a professional and
sit down and say those exact words you
just said to me yeah I'm I'm already on
the schedule I just can't get it until
next month but it's already in the works
okay I want you to go sit down in front
of that person who you see and if when
you walk in if you're shoulders don't
drop immediately I want you to just
leave well you've waited a long time so
go ahead and have the first session okay
but you'll need somebody not to over
clinical IE you you're going to need
somebody that sees
you because what your body needs right
now is not more information your body
needs someone to look at you and say I
love you just because you walked in the
door and I'm so glad you're here because
you don't do that for
you and this sounds bananas but the
single greatest gift you can give that
husband of yours who's awesome those
kids of yours that are awesome is a mom
and a
wife that is really um proud to be
her and that sounds like a thousand
miles away that sounds like I'm making
fun of you right doesn't it sounds so
ridiculous to say that it it makes it a
different I mean changing the
perspective about it being about my boys
and about my marriage rather than just
me but it seems like it's a goal I want
to get there but I have absolutely no
idea how to get there here's how you do
it you sit down in front of somebody
face to face and say the exact same
things you just said to
me I've got everything everything I ever
wanteded and when I'm getting dressed in
the morning I stop and I look at myself
before I'm dressed and I drop my
shoulders and I'm
sad because I don't not only do I not
like what I see I don't like the person
I
see and I want to love
me I want you to start there with your
counselor my promise is there's healing
on the other side of that and then that
little four-year-old little boy is not
going to be trying to make mom feel
better about mom because he loves you
more than life itself and that husband
of yours just looks over and sees
beautiful
you and he hates the fact that somebody
hates the woman he loves so much it just
happens to be you I'm proud of you so
proud of you today is day
one and keep listening to mind pump guys
into Lane my buddy Jordan s keep
listening to those
guys they'll give you the the
tools but all that stuff is symptom
let's go beneath it let go sit down with
somebody and say I want to learn to love
me it's time I want to love me as much
as my little boys do it's a good place
to start
we'll be right
back hey what's up good folks delone
here listen researchers tell us that the
average person spends about a third of
their life sleeping that's about a
quarter of a million hours and we know
this for certain restoring your mind and
body with sleep is crucial to your
physical emotional and relational health
so if you're going to be sleeping for
onethird of your life and sleep is
critical for every good thing you've got
going on why not not try to get the best
sleep possible and great sleep starts
with an amazing mattress like dreamcloud
dreamcloud mattresses are soft cool and
supportive so you can sleep comfortably
all night I know because some of my
family sleeps on dreamcloud and here's
another bit of research for you four out
of five people say they fall asleep
faster on their dreamcloud than they did
on their old mattress and right now John
delone show listeners can get an awesome
deal 40% off all mattresses plus an
extra savings of $50 go to dreamcloud
sleep.com and enter promo code John
deloney that's dreamcloud sleep.com with
promo code John
deloney all right let's roll out to
Omaha Nebraska hey is Omaha where they
have the Omaha
Stakes I would assume so right I I mean
I've not been there personally but I
think it's probably a safe
assumption what's good talk to James
what's up James hey John how's it going
man we're partying dude what's up
man uh well I'm guess I'm just going to
roll uh right into the question um so my
wife and I are on the brink of a
divorce and so my question for you I
guess the best way I can put it is how
do I navigate
uh you know these emotions and
everything that's going on and really
try to find myself right now because you
know obviously my sense of self is kind
of all over the place at the moment yeah
what happened
man um I got to go back a little ways so
I've struggled with uh varying degrees
of anxiety my whole
life and um it's you know ebed and
flowed ups and downs but right before we
got married I I really hit the lowest
point in my life with my anxiety and um
I was just in pure survival mode for
like a year or more maybe um and so I
just couldn't be the best partner in the
world and so um the you know kind of the
Romantic and intimate part of our
relationship really started to uh fade
away
and ever since that point we've just
never had the tools or or understanding
of how to kind of bring that back and
really strengthen that side of our
relationship uh we were always really
good support systems for each other and
really best friends and still went out
and made a ton of memories together but
that side of the relationship never
truly recovered hold on why why did
y'all choose that somebody chose that or
yall chose it
together uh
we're we're both really good at
avoiding the tough conversations the the
awkward conversations I know but hold on
a sex don't avoid that it's like one of
the best parts second yeah you're about
to lose
everything and so if you're like
somebody who wants to avoid conflict and
you see a child about to walk in front
of a
truck you're like I'm just not good at
at at at hard
conversations and then he gets hit by
the truck like your marriage is almost
over yeah why not have the
conversations well we've we've been
having the
conversations um you know but
obviously uh a little late in the game I
don't believe
the G I don't believe in late in the
game well so let me let me run through
what she is telling me then
um she you know over the past six months
to a year she started uh you know talk
about how she feels trapped and
claustrophobic both just in the
relationship in her life uh her job
where she lives I mean just kind of
everything about her life right now she
just kind of feels uh claustrophobic I
guess was the word she used and um you
know recently she's been talking about
you know she doesn't know if she wants
to be here
anymore um and she just doesn't have
hope that the relationship can be
changed and the real I guess final
kicker was she told me that she doesn't
even know if she wants to try
to uh heal the relationship I guess
she's been married to a a light
socket yeah
so I what you just the way you just laid
that out what she said tells me that's
the sound of somebody who's exhausted
they're out because they're trapped in
an umbrella or like in a dome of well
it's just the anxiety it's just the
anxiety it's just the
anxiety yeah and even your language is
super
defeatist but listen dude like this
thing this anxiety it's not something
you have it's not something that like
descends upon you like Co
did
right right it's a whole bunch of little
bitty choices that you make over a
period of
time and so my question she's not on the
phone so I can't talk to her but I'll
ask you why have you allow what like
what is it about this that that is an
identity for you that's so powerful that
you're willing to lose your marriage
over it you're willing to have a sexless
marriage you're willing to have a
marriage where you don't have
conversations with your best friend in
the
world yeah I mean so I've been I've been
working really hard on myself within
like the last year um i' found a
therapist that I love uh and I've been
working really hard but it's
just I I have I have reached out and
tried to what what does working really
hard mean cuz I don't believe you I say
that cuz I love you but I don't believe
you like what does working really hard
mean uh well like I said you know going
to therapy and having a lot of tough
conversations with my therapist here's
what it sounds like here's what it
sounds like it sounds like you have a
lot of
conversations and you have a lot more
conversations after that and then you
think a whole whole bunch and then you
read a book and listen to some podcast
then you have some more conversations
and your wife's like can we just have
sex is that
fair yeah I mean but it's also a
reciprocation thing because I I I feel
like I have come to the table um you
know let's try this let's go to this
let's do this and it it just seems like
we just sit and spin our tires rather
than actually move forward with the
process of of doing said things and and
actually working towards the the healing
part of it if that makes
sense yes
and okay can I just can I be like super
honest with you because I love you
absolutely man all right so the father
of existential psychology the great
Irvin yolum
um he he kind of took up this this um
this mantle if you will this baton of
teaching future
therapist and he said as one of the
greatest um tools a therapist has in
their toolkit is everything is
data and he said so what that means is
as a counselor if one of your clients
comes in and every time they come in
you're just so distract you can't pay
attention you're like find yourself
nodding off you find yourself like keep
having inside your mind like I got to
come back got to come back that in it of
itself is data and a true loving
counselor would ask the person do other
people think you're boring do other
people say that you're hard to be around
because I'm struggling and maybe that's
where the work is okay so I tell you all
that to tell
you I'm struggling to connect with you
because every time I'm trying to connect
you Loop it around and have like well
and actually what we talked about is and
I can get this picture tell me I'm crazy
that you are like okay or intimacy is
off it's not good I'm struggling with
anxiety I've had lots of Hard convers
ations
honey we're going to do a sex
thing and it's going to be a this and
it's going to be at that and then we're
and so really your wife instead of
entering into this her coming home and
the whole house has roses everywhere and
there's candles I don't know what she's
into and Tori Amos is playing and I or
Olivia Rodriguez is like I don't know
what she's into but whatever her thing
is instead of
that she gets off of work and feels like
she's going to an exam like a final exam
a test that she needs to pass so her
husband who's anxious out of his
mind can be a little bit more of the
husband she signed up
for do you see the difference one of
these is a project and one of these is
part of my homework assignment between
me and my counselors I'm going to go
home I'm going to go for it I'm going to
be recklessly vulnerable with my
wife and I'm going to feel the tension
in my body but I'm not going to put that
on her that's she's not have to her job
isn't to perform for me and make sure
she does everything right
so that we can be intimate whatever
intimacy looks like it could be doing it
but it could be any a whole bunch of
other stuff too do you see what I'm
saying yeah absolutely absolutely am I
right or wrong tell me if I'm wrong man
call me out if I'm if I'm
off no you're you're definitely you're
definitely right it's
just I guess I don't know how to
necessarily get to that point you know
what I
mean you have to decide to so recklessly
run into to the fire and through the
smoke and you're not your wife is
standing there in that fire getting
burned and you're like all right so what
we're going to do today is we are going
to examine the smoke and she's like will
you just come here with
me and it and and I'll be super honest
with you man I'm all about reality it
may be too late she may have checked
out and that's okay I mean it's not it's
not it's not okay like in the it's going
to hurt and be a back to your original
question like how do you find yourself
we can talk through that real quick but
I don't think that's the thing right
now I think your wife has probably felt
like she's responsible for making sure
you're okay for so long and you have
been really working hard intellectually
through these
things and there's got to be a place
where there's connection and you're
trying to connect intellectually and
you're trying to connect project based
learning and she just wants
you yeah see and I hope you get what I'm
saying I I I do I do it's the difference
between like I am going to
rip your top two buttons off of your
shirt in a passionate kiss
or when I get home I will unbutton the
top button followed by the next top
button right
the same things happening but one of
those is like this moment of Reckless
abandon and she might say hey stop and
that's going to be scary for you that's
vulnerability or she may rip your shirt
back but it's different than this
clinical stepbystep process where she
feels like she's being tested yeah
because none of us like to be in in math
class for the rest of our lives with the
one person we're supposed to be able to
drop our shoulders
with is she seeing somebody else
El I I I firmly believe no I mean I
we've I've asked her that we you know I
I I honestly do not believe that to be
true no okay she's got to be getting
connections somewhere and maybe that's a
friend maybe that's a Fantasy Life maybe
that she's just shut the whole machine
off for now and she's tired of like
that's what that trapped feeling might
be that she's tired of having the whole
machine
off yeah I I think it's think it's uh
not necessarily in love with someone
else but in love with something else I
think she's in love with the idea of not
being uh slowly being encased in
concrete yeah right like this this
impending sense like I got I gotta get
out of here whatever here is here may be
you but it may be the whole feeling of
that whole situation so do you think
there's a chance to save your marriage
or are you guys pass that is she filed
on
you no that there hasn't been any fil
uh we we don't have any kids or anything
so
it's it's there's not a lot to it in
those terms um hold on homie there's a
lot to
it it might not be as complicated but it
will still be as
violent right
right I think we're both kind of just in
this limbo of of what what do we do what
are the next steps either way you know
so if one of you files on each other the
moment somebody files the relationship
is over and it is now a business
transaction and this is uncomfortable to
say but you don't business transaction
season is not the time to quote unquote
work on
yourself you're in the middle of a
business deal and we're going to get
through that
deal right and then we're going to let
the smoke and dust clear and we're going
to try to make good choices during the
smoke and dust and when I say make good
choices we're not going to do anything
we can't take back we're not going to go
get somebody pregnant we're not going to
just immediately start dating all over
the place we're not going to um eat with
Reckless abandoned we're still going to
go exercise we're still going to try to
sleep best we can even though we're
grieving like crazy you will have some
Netflix nights you'll have some of that
kind of stuff but we're going to do the
best we can to stay whole we're going to
have a group of guys that we hang out
with that we do life with we're going to
be whole through this business
transaction and then we're going to
start asking what now where do we go
most people make mistake when somebody
files they instantly like want to go
David gogin the whole thing and you
can't because your body's in fight ORF
flight and grief at the same time it's
not a time to start a new program of
some sort you got to get through this
thing right it's like being in the
middle of a
marathon and all of a sudden you have
you're like I'm gonna start a squat
routine like like dude finish the race
first got to finish the race and then
you got to rest and then you can start
talking about squats right so finding
yourself that's this isn't the time if
if yall getting divorced there's a
business
transaction right I also think there's a
place to sit down and
say I'm not out if you are I don't
believe in two sentences I don't believe
in too soon I just I don't know I just
think things are funny even if it's
awful like I don't believe in too soon
and I don't believe in too late it's too
late I don't believe
that and so to sit down and
say I realize that me getting well or
trying to get
well has put you in a microscope for the
last however many years and that's
exhausting I'm
sorry and you brother have to stop
wearing anxiety as a identity badge as a
way you walk around the world this is
this is my this is the way I do
it and you have to take those
intellectual conversations that you have
and those lessons that you think about
and think about those hard conversations
and you have to start doing things
differently and that means you're gonna
have to start getting
tougher and I don't mean that like I
don't feel my anxiety I mean tougher
like I'm going to do things when I don't
feel like it I'm going to exercise when
I don't feel like it I'm going to go to
work and be on time when I don't feel
like it I'm going to ask my wife every
single day of my life how can I love you
today
I am going to put on my
calendar make a move
tonight put on her music create a world
take care of the dishes take care of the
things that that that all the the whole
environment that take your foot all the
gas pedals down and all the brakes off
in the house whatever that looks
like and I'm going to be vulnerably
recklessly vulnerable with my
wife not problem-based learning and her
being have taking the SAT every Saturday
night when youall want to hook up but
man all in and that's probably going to
be some some skills that you got to
learn how to do and it's going to be
really vulnerable and scary you're worth
that by the way and what a fun way to
live man that's you running through the
fire and letting your body know I get
I'm I'm getting your signals but she's
safe she's amazing and by the way you
may do all of this and she may still
leave and if she does you're going to
have to grieve it
hard but why leave it on the
table don't leave a conversation unad
don't leave an experienced
untried go get your
wife go get your wife we'll be right
back hey good folks delone here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time those become healthy
habits they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling hallow makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com dealone today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hall.com
dealone for 90 days
free all right let's go out to Little
Rock and talk to Ashley what's up
Ashley hi good morning Dr John how are
you we're so good how about you I'm I'm
doing great I I am a little nervous I
have to tell you but I'm I'm very
grateful for your time today don't be
nervous I'm not that good I'm not good
at this what's up so I'm calling because
I I have a lot of uh conflicting
feelings of guilt and resentment toward
my mom that I'm hoping you can help me
work through what' she do um so I'll
I'll try to be succinct but basically my
my parents had a very tumultuous
marriage during which my dad was
unfaithful pretty much throughout that
entire relationship and he was em
emotionally and and on one occasion
physically abusive with her as well and
after they split up and and my dad left
you know my mom really stepped up to
take care of me and my brother so I've
always held her in a very high regard
because of that um but the guilt and
resentment comes in uh because I I moved
I moved away um I moved out of state
with my boyfriend a few years ago and in
my culture that's kind of unusual and
and round upon I guess and so she's
really kind of guilted me of for that
over the years and um has badmouthed me
and my relationship to various family
members and and friends um and I think
I've just realized how much she's put on
me uh to kind of take care of her
emotionally throughout my life so I I am
struggling because I um love her to
death but I I have a lot of anger toward
her um that I I don't really know how to
work through I guess to put it in short
no I appreciate that so I wonder if the
anger that you have towards
her
is potentially a more Universal anger
that I wanted this picture to be
celebrated by everybody and it's not so
I wonder if your anger is actually
grief I that may be part of it I think
there's there's more to the anger if I
can give you a couple of sure examples
perhaps so um for instance in the one uh
instance where my dad was physical with
her you know she um I I was maybe 11 and
it happened in front of me and and she
asked months and months later you know
why I didn't do anything to stop him at
the time um and she also doesn't have a
lot of people close to her so she chose
to confide in me and my brother you know
throughout my dad's uh affair with his
mistress and now wife so she would tell
us you know all of the updates and show
us emails and like sext messages between
them um um so I I think just putting
that on us as young kids has made me
feel um I I don't know conflicted in the
the appreciation that I have for her but
a lot of anger in the way that you know
she's dealt with me moving out but also
just how she's kind of dealt with my
parents relationship um as we were
growing up that's
like I'm sorry that happened that should
never have
happened
she shouldn't have done that to her
kids and that was never y'all's burden
to
carry the challenge is with our
parents is can we hold the good stuff
and can we hold the bad stuff at the
same time and what do we choose to do
with those
things
and I I was on the phone with my mom as
I was driving in this morning I love my
mom I love my dad I love my
in-laws but they don't get a vote into
how I choose to deal with the
emotions and you've got some of these
parts of your mom that were amazing and
she was so strong and she survived what
was
hell and she dragged her little kids
through it
too both in both stories are
true
where where the next step breaks down is
you're still going back to your mom
trying to solve that dilemma and that's
not her Dilemma to solve it's yours in
the same way she was bringing you along
why didn't you protect me from
this which she should have never done no
parent should put that on an 11-year-old
little girl my
God no piece of crap Dad should hit
their
mother uh especially in front of a kid
no I'm not going to say especially just
ever but also not in front of a kid like
all of
it but in the same way right now you're
holding your grief you're holding your I
can't believe this happened and you're
circling back and trying to get your mom
to solve it she
can't and so you I don't know how to
work through it myself yeah well and
you've probably heard me use this
analogy a lot
but as a little kid you were born into a
household and you had a backpack on and
your dad kept dropping bricks in that
backpack and a couple times your mom and
your dad put cinder blocks in that
back and you've been carrying that
sucker around not to mention your
boyfriends and those breakups and the
stupid thing that your girlfriend told
you one time and your own things that
you've experienced right and now how old
are you 28 28 with a backpack that
weighs 5,000 lbs and it's so
heavy
and instead of taking the bricks out of
your backpack just setting them down I'm
not carrying this
anymore you're hunched over trying to
hold this thing up and your legs are
shaking and your shoulders are burning
and you're looking at your mom asking
her why she put them in there that's who
I mean she
did there will never be an answer that
takes the weight off of your back that's
your job that's your adventure to go
do so one of the things I often tell
people is to literally go to the
store go to Home Depot or Lowe's and buy
a cinder block and put a piece of duct
tape on
it and write
down the time you called me in and asked
me why I didn't stand between an abusive
man and
me and I want you to walk around your
backyard and just carry that thing until
it's so heavy it's hard to
hold and I want you to go find a place
in your backyard
and set it down and rip the the the
thing on throw it down and never pick it
up again but have this cathartic like
you know you go to a funeral there's a
before and after and the funerals are so
important because it gives your body an
anchor point a period at the end of a
sentence and we can shift from person to
Spirit like this this like you now
you're a part of my memory you're part
of me but I can't pick up a phone and
call you what you're doing is a very
similar thing mom you put this B this
brick in my backpack I'm not carrying
your stuff anymore no
more and then I want you to write a
letter to that 11-year-old little girl
and tell her that you're sorry that she
went through that cuz she should have
had a mom that didn't drag her through
that and she should have had a
dad they didn't beat up her mom and they
didn't fill the house with so much fear
and didn't cheat on Mom and drag other
women through
right there's 11-year-old little girl
trying to figure out what was so bad
about her that Dad took off and there's
11 11-year-old little girl trying to
figure out oh man maybe I should have
done something for a
mom it was never that little girl's
job so I have a a question about that um
if I how how can I continue to have my
mom in my life you know right now I I
have so much dread when I think about
going home
um feel that way has opted out on
you because she continually belittles
you in the choices you've
made she continues to talk bad about you
if behavior is a language she is telling
you I don't want to be in relationship
with you until you do what I want you to
do to make me feel better about
myself and I would tell you it's
unethical to continue to go home when
you resent her for going that's on
you so you hear me say all the time
choose guilt over resentment every
time and so practice this
year I think I've I think I've said on
the show every September my f my wife
and I send an email out to the family
here's what our travel plans are going
to be for Thanksgiving and Christmas and
it's usually based on a conversation my
wife and I have what's the tra what's my
travel season been like what's her
writing season been like what's our kids
like schedules been like and what's our
financial situation this year like what
are we going to do but we get to pick
that and then if my mom decides to get
super angry and mad she's a grown woman
she gets to do
that that's her choice that's not I
can't fix that for
her and if you listen to your the
language that you're speaking you're
still on a 11-year-old little girl
trying to figure out how to make Mom
okay and I want you to hear me say you
can't you never
could and well here's my promise if you
broke up with that boyfriend and you
moved back
home mom would have a comment about your
weight mom would have a comment about
your job Mom would wonder why you're
driving that car mom would wonder why
because that Finish Line's always going
to move because your mom's not okay with
who your mom is and she's dubbed you the
person to make it right
and you
can't you see what I'm
saying I do I just I feel guilty
thinking about I know you do leaving her
I guess you're not leaving her she left
you a long time ago Ashley she's using
you now to feel better about
herself she doesn't love the Ashley that
is living her life in Little Rock
Arkansas all she loves the version of
Ashley that she wants Ashley to be so
that she can tell people at The Rotary
Club I don't know if she goes to Rotary
Club but whatever
right yeah you're a chess piece in her
game and do I think she loves you of
course she does do I think she's an
exhausted abused woman absolutely yes
has she been through hell no question
about
it but that's her work to choose to
do and by the way I don't think this has
to be some big announcement some big
grandiose talk I think it's hey we're
not traveling this year for the holidays
we'll FaceTime in and we're really going
to miss
you and if that causes a lot of drama
then she gets to I me that's her drama
to to cause and if she really wants to
sit down and have a conversation we can
do that in person we can do that if she
wants to come
visit or maybe on the phone Mom you've
made it super clear for the last four
years you don't like me you don't like
my
life you didn't like me when I was 11
and I wasn't able to defend you you you
haven't ever liked
me so let's stop the dance and the
charade if we want to build something
new a new motherdaughter relationship
I'm all
in but I'm tired of you thinking less of
me I'm tired of you not liking me I'm
tired of you not loving
me for who I am I'm
tired and stop carrying that brick
around there is no way through this let
me say it this way you're going to have
to choose your hard
path there's no easy path
out you can choose your heart and go to
Thanksgiving and Christmas and have her
not like you and have her go through the
things and complain about everything and
why didn't you oh my gosh can you
believe your dad that one time you can
do that that's hard that's a hard way to
live or you can do another hard thing
which is to make some pretty firm
boundaries treat her with love and
dignity and respect and at the same time
treat yourself with love and dignity
dignity and
respect and go about living a life
that's going to make you
whole not go on living a life that you
can try to play whack-a-mole with your
's emotions and feelings and try to make
her feel good about her life you
can't but there is no easy path there's
no way that you feel feel super great
but just because you don't feel great
doesn't mean it's not the right
move I'm going to send you a copy of
building a non-anxious life I want you
to read this book for you for the first
time for you and I want you to begin to
look at these choices these six daily
choices you can
make how could I begin
to invite warmth and laughter and joy
and peace into my home and I think for
you it's going to be starting with
owning reality choosing
reality choosing this fact that like
this is what I got and I got to choose
to do something
[Music]
different I wish I had like some like oh
yeah just call her and say this but
that's not the way this
works it's you deciding I'm going to
choose reality I'm going to take
ownership of
life and if Mom's opted out I hate that
I got to grieve
it but I want more from me you're worth
it we'll be right
back hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today at johal.com
all right we're back as we wrap up
today's show we got um am I the problem
it's me right yep you ready awesome I'm
super ready and we have some people who
came at the the show last night and
they're here so we'll let them weigh in
too all right I'm not reading this
person's name she asked us not to okay
hold on thumbs up if she's the problem
thumbs down if she's not the problem
okay all right go all right I'm really
struggling with the thought of doing
Christmas this year with my in-laws my
husband and I have been doing Christmas
with them every years every year for the
past six years it's the only time that
we go to see them and I dread it every
year they don't do anything special for
the holidays no decorations Specialty
Foods Christmas music movies Etc the
house is usually really dirty and
there's never any food prepared the
hardest part of the whole visit is that
no one ever asks about how our life is
going if we bring up exciting news about
something important to us they quickly
get back to a story about them or
completely disregard what we say they
know so little about our lives and it
breaks my heart for my husband he can't
share anything with his own family it
also stresses out my husband when we go
see them he often says he misses his
family but then every time we go he gets
very anxious I've talked to him about
skipping this year and he became very
sad when I broke when I uh brought it up
am I The Jerk for wanting to skip
Christmas with them this
year yeah no she's not she's not um in
fact I would say you're a wife that
deeply loves her husband um and it's
it's kind of like if every time you ate
at a restaurant that only served tacos
and your husband got tacos and he got
firebomb diarrhea every time you'd
finally start saying like hey let's stop
going to that
restaurant except this time
that restaurant is his family and he
goes every year and he gets sick and he
gets anxious and he gets worked up and
he wants to share his life with him um
she said something in there
he she feels so bad that he can't that
he can't share parts of his life with
them and he gets anxious yeah uh that um
he he says he often misses his family
but then every time we go see them he
gets very anxious he doesn't miss his
family he's grieving the fact that he
wanted his family to want to be he
wanted them to be interested in his life
and they're not and so the only thing I
would tell her instead of saying hey
let's don't do this provide an
alternative vision for I really want to
go do
this I want this year so I'm I like to I
have this thing like every year I want
to go see this family and this family
and this family and do these things and
I love going this isn't my house at all
but the travel part is what wears me out
cuz I'm running around and it was when
my wife it was last year my wife said
not hey I don't let's just don't travel
this year you're burned out I would have
felt guilty about that be like no I'm
not going to not see my family they're
amazing because I'm whatever instead she
said hey this year I'd really love if
just me and you and the kids got a hotel
for a couple of nights at this place in
Nashville and we just had a fun
time and she said that I had a picture
of that and I was like oh that sounds
incredible right and so it wasn't me not
doing this thing it was
us doing this thing together and so
provide an alternative picture don't
just burn one to the ground but provide
something else that we can go to not we
can just go from I think going towards
something is always more sustainable and
joyful than not doing sometimes you have
to not do it to stay alive but man
there's more lifegiving going towards
something so that's what I think what do
you think yeah oh 100% yeah I think
they've made it clear that they
don't and how awful to go to someone who
they there's no celebration there's no
no food I mean that's the
holidays what what is that different
than any other time of year exactly hey
and everybody voted correctly way to go
y'all that's awesome all right hey thank
you'all for joining us be nice to each
other go pick up build an non anxious
life and make your holiday plans right
now and choose guilt over resentment if
this isn't the year to go if this is the
not the year to buy gifts if this isn't
the
year take ownership of that be kind and
respectful and send the messages and
then feel
it it's going to feel real good I love
yall
[Music]
bye